yeah
[Music]
sure have you got many that are waiting
for beds the pace is relentless
Jared how are we doing on inbound
ambulances Dr Sutherland and her
emergency team at King's College
Hospital must constantly be prepared for
the unexpected who came through here we
had a transfer right with with a
subarachnoid temperature cake obviously
exhausted frustrated and they're losing
stuff
there hasn't been a down time there
hasn't been a rest I mean we're
incredibly lucky here we've got a really
strong team spirit but there's no doubt
we're losing staff because it is
relentlessly busy
the winter is unlikely to bring respite
with warnings over a so-called twin Demi
that's covered and flu
we still have patients who either have
another disease but have covered also
and we still have some patients who are
directly affected by covert so is the
pandemic over as far as you're concerned
the pandemic isn't over but like
everyone else we're learning to live
with covid as one of the respiratory
viruses that we treat
one in eight people in England are
waiting for operations or other types of
care this trust performs around
150 surgeries every day to try and cut
through the backlog while the government
has made the waiting list a priority the
workforce wants more support one of the
things that we'd really like to see is
is it national investment in National
Health Service staff so so more doctors
more nurses because those are really the
engines of treating patients and in
terms of disease prevention and
investigation obviously those things are
massively important as well
Staffing pressures aren't restricted to
hospitals some one in seven patients are
in a hospital bed when they should be at
home getting better but there isn't any
social care provision for them and it
isn't safe so the prime minister's
decision to prioritize social care is
being seen as a positive step
trust leaders accept they need to find a
way to do more with the resources they
already have
and we need to be more efficient and we
need to be more productive and of course
one of the key issues that we need to
make sure there's adequate flow out of
hospitals into social care so that we've
got that flow all the way through the
hospital this is
we think now this is not so much a
hospital problem this is a system issue
what service has already
or equivalent of winter pressures this
year so there will be no less up as it
braces itself for the real thing Ashish
Josh is Sky News at the King's College
Hospital in London